qu'est ce que tu te dis tous les
matins quand tu me vois dans le miroir
l'insécurité
j'aimerais changer que
tu aies passé ton enfance dans une
commune d'acteurs et de musiciens
croyants d'une
organisation spirituelle qui s'appelle
euh
c'est quoi
c'est une question très intéressante euh ben
c'est pas une religion c'est juste c'est
mes parents et ben c'est une
fraternité spirituelle euh les
gens façon d'adorer dieu mais ce n'est
pas une secte c'est juste
comme vous savez que les gens méditent
c'est comme ça euh fait une forme de
méditation juste
toi et dieu
juste la prière ce n'est rien euh
fou
ou par
froid ou étrange ça
devient juste  plus proche de Dieu
et tu peux être n'importe quelle religion et
ce n'est pas une religion
à l'âge de 13 ans tu étais en contact
avec la drogue
oh mon dieu
je
n'étais pas la plupart des adolescents américains
euh oui euh ado américain  ager oui mais
ils l'ont rendu dans la presse beaucoup plus
fou qu'il ne l'était je viens de dire oui
quand j'étais jeune j'étais un pot je
vous savez mais ils le font
tellement plus je n'ai jamais été toxicomane
et euh
c'est  pas quelque chose dans lequel
je pense que les jeunes devraient vraiment se lancer
parce que c'est stupide et ça ne
mène nulle part vraiment
alors quand j'étais jeune ouais j'ai essayé ça
comme tous les adolescents américains c'est un gros
problème en Amérique
tu es rare si tu ne le fais pas
mais  euh
tu sais que
je ne sais pas maintenant alors qu'est-ce que ça ne veut pas dire
il y a un an tu
étais un supporter de dukakis euh comment
expliques-tu son échec
qui sait
évêque qui était évidemment euh
[Musique]
il avait le pied
là-dedans depuis longtemps  il y a du temps
et euh la seule chose qu'on peut espérer c'est
que
les républicains tombent sur leur face et qu'un
très bon démocrate arrive dans les
quatre prochaines années
c'est la seule chose qu'on peut espérer
euh
je ne supporte ni Bush ni aucun des siens
politiques
pendant le tournage de euh désespérément
cochant donc vous avez eu des problèmes wi  th madonna
non
jamais
c'est une autre chose il y a une
fable mythique complète que les gens ont écrite à propos de don
et je suis des amis très proches
nous n'avons jamais eu de problèmes nous nous
aimons et c'est la presse et les
journalistes qui ont fait d'une grande histoire un gros
mensonge
vous pouvez  demandez à madonna vous demandez nous sommes
amis cela n'a jamais été un problème parfois
vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec luke pason et euh
vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec la façon dont il vous a coupé
dans le film mais euh pensez-vous que
ce lupus a beaucoup à apprendre sur
les femmes
je pense que luke est un bon cinéaste je pense
qu'il est jeune
et je pense que je vais retravailler avec
lui et j'espère que dans peut-être trois ans nous
ferons un autre film et je suis très heureux
de le faire parce que je sais qu'il va grandir
beaucoup pour que les gens puissent voir la version longue
et voir ce que j'essayais de faire pourquoi
j'étais là
mais euh ouais je pense qu'il
comme tous les jeunes hommes les
femmes en
savent
plus à cet âge que les hommes et je pense que
cela
prend beaucoup plus de temps aux hommes pour  vraiment comprendre la
femme et vous devez avoir un certain âge y  ous
devez avoir de l'
expérience
et luke obtient tout cela très
vite je pense que dans trois ans son prochain
film quand il travaillera avec des femmes sera
très différent
j'ai hâte d'y être tu as dit euh
pour travailler avec scorsese tu le
ferais  pour rien jouer pour rien
sans même lire un script
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il a
le contenu de cet autre réalisateur
eh bien ce n'est pas une question de
ce que les autres n'ont pas c'est juste qu'il a
tellement plus
je veux dire bien est-ce que ça a du sens
non c'était stupide  euh
il sait juste comment dire la vérité et il
sait comment trouver
la vérité à l'intérieur de vous
et il sait comment faire ressortir cela
dans le travail
je vais faire un autre film avec lui
dans deux ans et je suis très excité  à propos de
ça je pense qu'il est
tu sais
le cadeau de dieu aux acteurs
quelle est la différence entre orchidée
et poli
arquette et
paulette beaucoup
tu veux dire le personnage que je joue paulette
dans les histoires de new york
euh
il y a l'
essence
d'elle de moi ou
de moi
en elle mais vraiment ça  était un autre
personne que je jouais
et euh
[Musique]
même si
j'ai j'ai une insécurité à propos de
choses physiques avec moi-même je me sens toujours
et je ne sais pas pourquoi je ne me
sentais pas comme ça parfois je suis moche je suis de la
merde mais euh
mais
mon dieu je n'ai aucun sens suis-je steve pocaro
james newton howard et maintenant
peter gabriel
vous semblez avoir une
étrange
attirance euh pour les musiciens euh
[musique]
ouais je suppose que j'aime leurs instruments
abner metampos blue